this is where astronauts go to get a
drink get it and catch that hotdog it's
episode 9 of IMG do you like girls but
also like Legos while you're in luck
last week dummy comm showed me Lego
sculptures for adults and BuzzFeed
collected 14 pictures of goats that will
kill you
this girl is similarly full of hate
until she's next to a mirror and her
shirt says love mow luge INSCOM calls
this the second best optical illusion
ever watch out don't let him eat I'm on
a horse best poker face ever and a
pretty girl wait wait what are you doing
no no no no no no stop stop stop stop
ah great now you're jared leto i love
flow charts and i love videogames but oh
hey look a flow chart that is an RPG if
you want to check it out you can find a
link to the image and all images here in
the description this is a neat painting
it's really fun to get closer sort of
zoom in and take a look
why because with this painting you can
never stop zooming Alfred Hitchcock was
molded from Minnesota and via our
Facebook page North America is a dragon
burlesque pointed me to Kobe Levi's
today his high heel designs include
bananas bubble gum stuck on your heel
slingshots and this cat's make
exercising dangerous and finally what
really matters zach galifianakis
photoshoot with Vanity Fair enjoy
that's it for IMG but hey take a look at
this
hi we're screen TV show and you're
watching Vsauce I am a huge fan of
screen team show so big thanks to them
for that intro in fact now that IMG is
over click here to see their halo parody
of Seelos you go ahead do it
IMG's over until next time thanks for
watching
[Music]